[Music]
on to the pandemic it's always with us a
new strain
yes a third one is worrying government
scientists it's from brazil
and the government's chief scientific
advisor admitted he didn't know if our
vaccines could protect
against it the government has come under
fire for reacting too slowly
to this new outside threat but it is
difficult these new threats seem to be
emerging all the time university college
london's professor francois balu
is one of the uk's leading experts in
genetics
his research lies at the intersection
between genomics
epidemiology evolution and ecology
so who better to shed light on this new
strain than him a professor welcome uh
to spectator
tv what can you tell us about this
new strain from brazil well we don't
know
that much about it um it has some
similarities with the strain we've been
seeing in circulation
in south africa in particular it has
one mutation which is i would say the
mutation we really worry a bit about in
terms of
immune escape let's say how well
vaccines will protect against it i'd
really like to stress that it's not an
immune escape strain at this stage it
might just
reduce the efficacy of the vaccines a
little bit
tell us what's happening when when the
the the
these strains uh mutate
um am i right in thinking that the
this is part of their survival is that
why they mutate
yes so mutations tend to be random and
from the beginning of the panoramic
uh let's say initially we have very
little variation in the virus probably
in the viral population
and then diversity has been building up
some mutations and on average every
strain acquires about 25 mutations a
year
so most of them do absolutely nothing
they have no effect on
on the virus um they don't make it
transmit better they don't make it
escape vaccines or immunity
but then there are a few that can change
the virus a little bit
and we haven't seen much happening until
very recently
but over i would say the last weeks we
have a few strains that seem to be
a bit more different so there is clearly
evolution going on there
is one of the differences professor is
that
one or two of these new strains we think
of what for a while was called the the
the the kent
virus that it seemed to spread more
quickly
than the the virus that we first
encountered in
march of this year yes there is some
good evidence that
this lineage which is becoming dominant
in the uk
now is more transmissible than the ones
we had before
so it is not escaping immunity
it is a bit unclear how it does actually
transmit better
there's still some uncertainty how much
more transmissible it is so i think
we'll have to
wait for a few weeks to put an exact
number on it
but clearly it's gone up in frequency
quite drastically
over the last weeks and is it a rule of
thumb
or not that when a virus mutates it may
use as you say it becomes more
transmissible
but does it does it weaken
when it mutates not absolutely
necessarily so
the only thing that matters for viral
violence and actually generally
evolution
is how well it replicates so that's the
only
only selective pressure on it whether it
hurts us or doesn't hurt us
that's actually not so important for god
it's not important
it's obviously very important for us but
not for for let's say the selective
pressures on the virus
now less symptomatic
less aggressive strains could be favored
if
they're not picked up people don't feel
ill people still move around
and they pass it on to others so that's
one mechanism by which viruses can
become more transmissible
but that's one of many and it's quite
difficult to make any predictions so
luckily this strain one seems to
transmit better
it doesn't seem it well it it
clearly doesn't create more severe
symptoms and not more lethal
and we'll have to wait for a little bit
to see what it might actually be
slightly milder
those of us who are not experts on this
the the thing that all work immediately
comes into our minds
when we read about some new strain of
the virus is
gulp will the vaccines that we're
putting
so much hope on now that's our kind of
get out of jail card
will the vaccines work against this new
strain
what's the story there so all the
evidence points to the vaccines work
working perfectly well against the
strain as well as
against any other strain so there's no
reason to believe that
vaccine efficacy would be lower against
the
kent or whatever you want to call it is
that a general feature
of of viruses professor
that that if you get a vaccine against
i mean i suppose the biggest vaccine
we've ever had uh in this year was
against smallpox
um and i'm sure smallpox must have
mutated
in lots of different ways but in general
if you get a good vaccine that works
in general it should be able to cope
with the mutating a virus
yes and no so small boxes is a bit
different it's a very slowly evolving
viruses the dna virus is a completely
different beast
i think here we what's probably more
comparable
is is the flu so influenza
and these are viruses that evolve quite
quickly and
as we all know let's say the fluid jab
needs to be
redesigned on a regular basis so
essentially people the most at risk
they say get vaccinated each year and i
think we have to prepare ourselves
to have to update the vaccine which is
not the end of the world so that's
technically very easy to do we have
excellent surveillance in place so we
know
what we have what we what to expect we
know what strains are emerging we know
which ones are of concern and in
principle
it won't be a major challenge to have
people
revaccinate it on a regular basis it
might not be
every year but i would say every
probably three four years
we'll have to let's say we vaccinate
the people who need to be vaccinated and
are we any clear on the week when the
who
investigators are arriving in china to
investigate the origins of the virus
in the work you've done on the genomic
data that you've been working on too
are we any clearer about the origins of
this virus
it jumped around october 2019 into the
human population it might have been
around a little bit earlier but let's
say
all the strains with sequins so far
that's
350 000 essentially they all have an
ancestor which dates back to
october to around october 2019.
and then it started spreading first
probably quite slowly
it reached italy quite early we have
good evidence that it was in italy in
november 2019
it wasn't really picked up initially and
then obviously
as we all know from late december
january on
we realized um there was a problem but
by then
it was actually probably fairly
widespread at least in europe
sorry professor onygo and then obviously
the question is
where did they come from um we know of
related fairly closely related viruses
that circulate in bats in
in china and the
we know actually have many of related
coronal viruses in
all sorts of animal populations bats
carnivores even birds
and these things are actually not
uncommon
and it can happen that they just jump
posts we also know that saskof2 has a
very broad host range so we can infect
humans but it can
prime it's going to have like cats and
dogs and and
and and whatever what not so
i think the the most
likely um scenario is that
it was some kind of natural spillover
from an animal but then obviously
when well where did what and it probably
happened
in china very very likely happened
around october 2019
and then obviously did it go through a
lab let's say was it stored in a lab
someone got infected
this is very very difficult to say what
i'd like to stress is that
we really have no evidence that it was
kind of engineered
by some nefarious muffins so it looks to
me
very natural when i look at it align the
sequence
against loads of other corner viruses i
can see
nothing really super special about it so
they
i mean one of the extreme conspiracy
theories that we don't need to dwell on
is that
china essentially intentionally unleash
this virus let's let's
park that the the the official story for
a while was it came from the wet markets
and
almost naturally but would it also be
possible that the
the lab in wuhan was working
experimenting with this virus doing
perfectly legitimate
scientific research into it and and it
got out
somehow it just kind of it lost it
yeah i think we cannot rule this out at
this stage and i hope there will be
proper investigation to clarify that but
even if it happened
to be absolutely brutally honest similar
things have happened before
and there's always a small risk that
let's say something can escape from a
lab
if i hope it won't happen and i hope we
will be more
careful in the future but these things
have happened in the past
there was some data i'd just like you to
to to mark our card on this from italy
we've got some people uh quite excited
in china
because it said the blood samples taken
in september had tested
positive for covert 19 antibodies and
the chinese societies say ah so it shows
that virus it didn't
originate with as if it was september
but
for those of us who are anything but
experts in this area
we just don't know what to make of that
what do you make of it yeah
there have been several similar claims
in the literature
including peer-reviewed journals i
have to say that these studies were not
particularly carefully performed
there's always a risk of false positive
this was
let's say this kind of test and if you
just screen samples especially
all terms they'll not be necessarily
conserved in perfect conditions
you can pick up some false positives and
i wouldn't say the evidence
is convincing at all the really
convincing evidence we have
is for cases in
december and november in france and
northern italy so actual cases there's
one
from early november child and it's
pretty convincing that this was an
actual case
and then we have some evidence from
wastewater also from northern italy
which suggests that it was in
circulation in december
interesting professor the i think the
in this what i might call the second
wave the the number of cases
the huge rise and the number of deaths
has taken a lot of people by surprise
certainly a lot of non-experts by
surprise from the government down and
january and february look like being
pretty dark days in britain and in other
countries too
our hope our optimism if there is any is
all around
the vaccine um as it's rolled out and we
in britain seem to be doing
pretty well compared to other countries
and rolling out that vaccine and
uh there's talk now that it could well
be about 19 million people
are getting it by the end of february
sometime into early march
up are we right to have that as
to to regard that as the light at the
end of the tunnel and the light is
not an oncoming train
i i absolutely agree so the vaccine is
will be absolutely essential to bring us
back to normal but let's say
the vaccine is is a brilliant beautiful
tool that will
help us getting back to
meaningful normal life a bit sooner
but fundamentally pandemics come to an
end
um now
there's an element of seasonality so i
would say
many people predict it actually this
winter wave predicted this winter wave
to be more
severe than the spring wave so that
that's really in line with what we know
from
enveloped rna viruses which have this
highly seasonal behavior
they transmit best in dry cold air
and obviously
by transmitting the in fact people and
people
gain immunity now obviously at a
terrible cost
and by having also a fraction
a large fraction as large as possible
population being protected
by the vaccine rather than infection we
obviously
decrease the burden quite dramatically
but that's really the burden in terms of
of mobility and mortality but
fundamentally the pandemic would come to
an end
more let's say there's no doubt about
that we had
we have experienced previous pandemics
let's see influenza dynamics in 1918
57 68 the mild one in 2009
when i say these it feels like the end
of the world but let's say there's
there's definitely
light at the end of the tunnel and also
the vaccine use is wonderful and it will
accelerate
let's say the ending of the pandemic
well we'll keep our eye on that light
even if it still seems a little far
away at the moment professor thank you
for the work you're doing in
this area and for your expertise and for
sharing that with us
on spectator tv today thank you
[Music]
you